I told Pauly I wanted to get Michael
Wilbon on he goes I my love will bond I
said well you're gonna really want to
hear what he has to say yes what do you
mean I said well I think he said this on
pardon the interruption I'm gonna tell
you something now that you're going to
think is preposterous Aaron Rodgers is
going to be in a Bears uniform sometime
in the next couple of years that's going
to happen all right we'll bond let me
start there good to see you Mike and I
just went I can understand from the
Packers standpoint drafting him they
made this work once they did the same
thing X number of years ago with Favre
and they drafted young Aaron Rodgers I
just don't necessarily get the arrogance
of it be we're not gonna tell them we're
not good and they pursued him it's like
Aaron Rodgers fell to the Packers when
they drafted him bruh this mean love
they they move they pursued and they
move him so you don't even clue Rodgers
in you went 13 and 3 last year
you knew knew neglected to get anybody
who might help him
I saw the stat last night that he's had
fewer passes touchdown passes to a
first-round draft pick they're like any
quarterback ever yeah certainly he was
one of the Hall of Fame and it's just
like wow so I I was joking around Dan
and then since then I've had all kinds
of people text me including summoning a
fellow who said you do you don't even
know how right you could be now it won't
be the Bears because the Packers just
won't deal into the Bears but it's gonna
be somebody I care about the bear so I
wanted it to be them it's gonna be
somebody it doesn't look like this is
gonna last for long does it Mike I think
it's gonna be the Tampa Bay Buccaneers
and he'll be known as Jolly Roger and we
put him in the Buccaneers uniform and he
takes over for Tom Brady it's too easy
Mike it's too although Dan dad even
presumes he would last like a year or so
more in Green Bay and I have to wonder
your Matt Lafleur the arrogance it's
unbelievable just can you handle it
differently do people never learn
anything about the way you handle
something and it
not well also you can't be on the job
for a year as I said yesterday it's
called the Lombardi Trophy not the
Lafleur trophy like let's slow down a
little bit and and all of a sudden if
it's true that you're tired of his
passive aggressive attitude they this is
the same attitude he has had I've known
him what 14 years he hasn't changed this
is who he is even before he became Aaron
Rodgers so you're gonna have him there
why signing to this contract if if you
don't like the passive-aggressive nature
you want to change your your philosophy
here you want to be more run for I got
it
I just don't understand how it seems
backwards with what they're doing hey
we're gonna sign you to this the riches
contract and then all of a sudden we're
gonna decide we want to change our
philosophy here you know it's he had 26
touchdowns four interceptions last year
that's a bad year for him because he's
being compared to him yeah this is like
this is the question is this a one-word
question you think when people watch the
last dance and they hear Jerry Krause
continually say in real time 22 years
ago he wants to you know Phil Jackson
you can't come back with me he's won
five why not why it just becomes why why
are you doing this why what what do you
met Lafleur and whoever the Jim I whose
name I can't pronounce what the hell are
you doing and you just ask the same
question over and over and of course Dan
they're not gonna supply an answer
because they don't have to which is the
ultimate in arrogance that's what it is
it's asking Jerry Krause what do you
want to get rid of still the scottie
pippen you found him you brought here
you drafted him what you brought Phil
Jackson in and sat on somebody else's
bench why do you want to get rid of him
they have no answer it's unbelievable
arrogance it just is I'll get to some
basketball stuff in a moment but if I
said you could have Cam Newton or Andy
Dalton as a backup quarterback with the
potential to compete for the starting
job who would you take since Andy Dalton
was released by the Bengals Andy doll
for backup I don't want Cam Newton in
there Cam Newton's used to being a big
star yeah I
it just is do I want Kim no if you ask
me without the goddess Olaf back the
quarterback who do you want more Andy
Dalton or Cam Newton I want Cam Newton
but you know I don't know the Cam Newton
is healthy of course but I also don't
know that I want Cam Newton there for
backup purposes because I don't think
that's if he's healthy
that ain't gonna last long and it may
not go well even if he is
yeah I'm right there with you I don't
think cam is wired to be a backup
quarterback I think Andy Dalton could be
a backup quarterback a couple of things
here obviously with the Jordan
documentary we were both there on the
front lines witnessing all of this is
there anything that you didn't know
through the first four episodes yeah so
like I mentioned we all knew the stress
between Jerry Krause and Phil Jackson
especially when you started bringing Tim
Floyd you know I choose daughter's
wedding
and you started having around the team
but Dan I don't think I knew he ever
told I know I didn't know he told them
if you go 82 and oh you still can't come
back that that is like the single most
drop dead line of all time and it's not
like isn't that like Phil Jackson was
put on him he courted Phil Jackson the
same way courted Tim Floyd have anyone
got him he tried to put him on another
coaches bench two years earlier staying
all mixed I that was that was the degree
of the animosity to me was sort of
stunning even though we were there yeah
you're right I forgot all about that
that you're going you could go
undefeated and you're still not keeping
your job but then I I think Jerry
Reinsdorf doesn't have blood on his
hands it's all on Jerry Krause and
that's not fair to Jerry Krause like the
owner can't I can't imagine that Jerry
Reinsdorf great businessman would have
said I'm gonna let Jerry Krause make
these multi-million dollar decisions
Jerry Reinsdorf see want to add to make
pay the money that's that's why this was
made he didn't want to be spending this
money on Michael and then you had Scotty
who was gonna want more money like I
don't know I think Reinsdorf doesn't he
gets off so far Scott
free no no you Dan you're right one
thing I wonder though and I think they
have to explain this in the doc and I
don't know if they will Jerry Reinsdorf
at that time only like 13% of the Bulls
I mean it's not like Jerry Jones you
know or Dan Schneider or somebody who's
got you know could complete control hey
old like 39 now is it's I don't know
what percentage it is there's a whole
lot more than that but I just wonder if
it didn't rise doors didn't metal
remember the White Sox team that won and
got rid of Frank Thomas and you had all
of that anxiety going on I shouldn't say
anxiety conflict
remember he left that to Kenny Williams
wait Kenny Williams was his president
and GM and Kenny Williams handled it and
at one point Oh Frank I get out I mean I
don't want it I don't want to see you
and the Hall of Fame first baseman while
you're trying to win your first World
Series since 1917 was banished and
Reinsdorf had nothing to do with it so I
approached there the Isiah Thomas stuff
I find fascinating just because it still
exists let me start with if I said you
had a bet a week's pay pardon the
interruption money that Michael didn't
want Isiah on the dream team and said
that to the Commissioner of the NBA you
would say what Michael Wilbon
well if if you I'll bet you that he
didn't want him no I didn't want on that
true now if the bet was that Michael
Jordan was the guy was the person who
prevented this I would bet you the other
way I would bet you did I bet you a
month's salary that that wasn't the case
then there were nine guys best of my
knowledge there were there were nine
guys who Italy you know so David
Robinson would never ever didn't want
anything right now in Stockton was just
sort of he was just acting like he
didn't know what he wanted and I don't
even know that they knew what he wanted
christian Laettner had no stripes so he
had no say in anything but it either all
nine or majority of a great majority of
those nine said they felt the same way
it was known how they felt they made it
known and so but Mike you had
daily I say as coach as the coach of the
dream team how does how does Chuck Daly
address that with Isiah it was probably
tense and remember if if Jerry Reinsdorf
has no blood on his hands
Chuck has none I mean you know I mean
look oh I think he was overruled I don't
think no no it was more than overruled
but Chuck knew did that team for that
team to function the way they wanted to
function they believed I'm not gonna say
this is true they believed remember at
that they believed that they didn't want
Isiah that it was gonna function that
way that summer they wanted to have like
a summer camp and so Bird and Isaiah had
had their dust-up magic and Isiah even
they had been best friends but not then
Michael Charles I mean it Karl Malone me
you could go through the roster again
the only one that you know would just
say I'm happy to be here I'm happy to
have anybody as David Robinson and I
don't even know that David Robinson has
had nothing to say but this was not
about Michael Jordan and stopping the
inclusion of Isiah Thomas they they're
way way more voices I just think that
the dream team was on vacation it was a
summer vacation they wanted to have fun
Michael wanted to you know have some
drinks cigars play golf and go out and
kick angle his ass that's it
he didn't care and Isiah would have been
a buzzkill he wanted to have fun with he
wanted to play golf with the coach Chuck
Daly
that's all Mike wanted to do he wanted
to have fun he wanted the environment to
have fun and I think that's probably why
he was saying I say it's not gonna be
fun he's not one of us yeah I don't
frame it in terms of what Mike wanted by
the time Mike signed on other people had
made whatever no no remember Thor
rothorn goes back to Michael Jordan and
since I got bird I got magic I got her I
got and Michael says okay good by that
point again Michael didn't have to Barry
didn't have to carry the weight of all
of that and I know it's it's tough to
dredge it but I've talked to Isaiah I
mean I know he's got to feel bad Isaiah
Thomas and I by the way I'm not I'm
to justify whether or not people should
have who they want on a summer camp team
I'm not gonna get into that issue but
Isaiah Thomas had made the Olympic team
in 1980 they didn't compete and and he
doesn't get the chance to be on in 1992
and so I know did this ooh by the way
this is a nice discussion to have Ron
Isaiah's 59th birthday like I get it I
get back like seeing all this again is
not making him feel great and I'm sure
the others say well the others their
position is he earned it right he was he
was the face of a great team and a
franchise that was a polarizing 40 min
franchise and beat us Michael Jordan
they went out yeah that team beat up
Michael Jordan do you think that Isaiah
froze out Michael in the all-star game
I think they probably all did I mean
it's too easy to frame it as I say a
versus Mike didn't have any Larry Bird
didn't operate on his own free will in
1985 of course he did if that was the
case that they were teammates I mean
didn't have anything but praise Larry
didn't have anything but praise for Mike
well yeah but God he said God disguises
I mean what is there a better compliment
that's ever been uttered about an
athlete all right before let me get this
Mark Cuban tweeted out he think that
thinks this Disney Resort possibility
could salvage the NBA season where you
get everybody in a centralized location
there's no travel you're gonna set up a
couple of basketball arenas you have a
couple of games a day you could televise
it you know it's everything on-site
there so what do you think about that
possibility it's everything on site with
a partner your partner Disney ABC ESPN
my old partner your all your old partner
your partner and so yes you've got all
that but let me ask you to stand and I
was had this posed to me by of
former player who would know it's just
let me ask you this so you're gonna have
21 and 23 and 25 and even 30 year old
men but but the ones in the early 20s
you're going to do what you're gonna put
on a hall monitor with us I know each
door are you gonna keep them from going
out at night you can't go on Instagram
any day now and not see first of all
professional athletes in a group of
others not to mention just people I just
saw the devil hooker Devin Booker got
into a car with one of the Jenner girls
the other day reportedly I mean that's
understandable but still they got the
basket ball park figure they got the TV
piece figured out they got the testing
part figured out oh wait we can't find
two of our guys you can't find what
everything is going right in the sea in
the world and now you're gonna find them
now
I seriously that's something they got it
that's a piece they gotta figure out did
you pipe in the the noise they're like
that feels like that's the Masters birds
that you've piped in there in your
background
remember it's early here it's earlier
three hours earlier on this because the
birds are still chirping okay it just
feels like it no I would not be up this
early if not for you did you pipe in on
Sunday you okay now is this the crib
that I've been to or did you guess you
upgrade oh okay Marky built how far you
from Berkeley about 15 minutes and you
play golf with him we have not done
anything that you know the golf courses
here are open dad yeah and you can get
out I have gotten out with my son to
play nine holes and he says dad the
first ace is dead
we're supposed to be six feet from
people right oh yeah he goes we're 300
yards from anybody huh what what's the
problem the golf course that's 12 right
and so Charles and I have talked a
couple of times but we have not convened
yet that would be you know your mood is
a lot greater here dad
I feel guilty a little bit about being
here instead of back east at home
I'll feel guilty enough to come back but
I but I I know the hardship and the
stress level is a lot greater than I I
would practice us you know social
distancing with my putting so if I'm six
feet away from the whole that's a gimme
Mike because I can't let it get closer
all right I know week Barkley invites it
wants us to do a show at his compound
good oh I know he says he goes I got a
guesthouse there and I said all right
listen I mean I hope I'm open as a
smoking cigars thing on the minute
oh yeah and so you could you get set up
up in that listen that'd be funny
Charles nice to meet Ian now invite
[Laughter]
nothing's changed much more birds I
think yeah apparently apparently tell
mr. Tony we settle oh great to talk to
you Mike thank you Michael that's a
Michael Wilbon